I heard a stranger audibly fart in a
bathroom the other day and it got me so
good I had to leave the bathroom and
then I just held my urine for hours
until I got to another bathroom
hey guys it is Wednesday on its grace or
once ever Wednesday our short I've been
traveling a lot for the Travel Show hey
you I say that mamrie and I have been
doing all summer so I've been really out
of the loop in terms of pop culture so I
went to a store in the airport and I
bought myself a pop culture magazine to
refresh myself on it and I thought that
together you and I would read this
magazine and just sort of take give it a
once-over
Tiger Beat Tiger Beat is a very notable
magazine for teenagers mostly and adult
perverts no I'm not I didn't set this up
well for myself you know when I was a
teenager I didn't read Tiger Beat I
think it was overwhelmed by the glamour
of it all I want to relate to you guys
on your level and find out what's going
on in your world so I'm educating myself
oh my god it's the hot boy mini mag a
mini magazine in China of regular sized
magazines with hot boys in it yes
they're all too young for me first
observation to Fisher these kids 24
pages of picks quizzes and stories that
may be too hot to handle we'll see about
that
ariana grande from day to night more
like Ariana in poquito little little bit
she's a little girl who are all of you
know you're all trying too hard that's
it I know these guys are sticking their
tongues out because they're just so
weird and quirky weird extra extra read
all about it
ed Sheeran crazy for hummus if I want a
lifetime without knowing that what kind
of life would that have been probably
fine Taylor kisses dating goodbye is
dating her like Norwegian boyfriend that
she just dumped just kidding she's
probably very nice I can't tell if these
are advertisements or if these are
articles fast facts with new crushes
it's time to fall in love ready set go
don't tell me how to live my emotional
life magazine with all the colors NIC
Morocco was born in 99
five that's not possible it's my
community magazine I got to it and tear
it up
who are you oh you're five seconds of
summer
[Music]
did it okay look one direction he's
going to a Wolverine face
that's all be patient hey you want a
role play I'll play Gretel you play
ansel woman crush Wednesday
seriously though Ross pause for this
brief intermission
[Music]
perfect boyfriend quiz certified words
that describe your perfect guy to find
out what trait really stands out okay
five um silly thoughtful hmm well this
is hard I'm taking this more seriously
than I thought I would be adventurous
clever and ambitious did I circle mostly
pink mostly blue or mostly purple I
circled mostly blue mostly blue means
I'm into his humor you love a guy that
can make you laugh so hard your stomach
hurts your dream boy who doesn't take
life too seriously is a-okay in your
book little do they know I don't own any
books other than my own Grace's
guidebook calm oh is this Ross the only
verse I enjoy played by David Schwimmer
okay here is my love scope it's a
horoscope but about love clearly the
only thing that teens are into is love
and that's Ross kit Libra you've been
waiting for your shot at love forever
and here's some great news now is the
time your patience was totally worth it
your dream guy notices you and is about
to make his first move swoon my love
match is Niall Horan wait till next
month then I don't know
no filter show tickets back down in the
description box Ross maybe there